hey this is presh talwalkar
if 4 and 2 combine to be 26
8 and 1 combine to be 79
and 6 and 5 combine to be 111
then what do 7 and 3 combine to be
this puzzle was tweeted by the
cooperative bank of kenya which is one
of kenya's largest banks
now if you configure this problem i have
a challenge puzzle for
you suppose you know that 7 and 3
combine to be z
i want you to find a different pair of
numbers x and y that also combine to be
z
i posted a similar puzzle previously and
very few people could solve this
challenge problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
before i explain the solution
i ask that you please subscribe to my
channel to get my newest videos
i also ask that you check out my books
which are listed in the video
description
if you like all of these topics please
support me on patreon every single
amount of support helps keep this
channel going and if you have a math
topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com
so with that in mind give this problem a
try and then i'm going to explain the
solution
so what's the pattern in this puzzle
let's do some basic arithmetic with the
numbers
four plus two is equal to six
eight plus one is equal to nine
and six plus five is equal to eleven
these numbers are part of the original
puzzle
now what happens if we subtract the
numbers
four minus two is equal to two
eight minus one is equal to seven
and six minus five is equal to one
and these are the remaining numbers in
the puzzle
so we figured out the pattern
to combine a and b
we take a minus b
and then we concatenate that with a plus
b
now to reduce confusion when we combine
two numbers
i'll mark the plus sign with a red
circle over it
so
the question is what do seven and three
combine to be
well seven minus three is equal to four
and seven plus three is equal to ten
so that's our answer four hundred and
ten
so now let's go to the challenge problem
we figured out that 7 and 3 combine to
be 4 10.
we now want to find a different pair of
numbers x and y that also combine to be
410.
we might try solving this by a system of
equations
we want x minus y to equal four
and x plus y to equal ten
but if we solve this system of equations
the only solution is x equals seven and
y equals three that's the unique
solution to this set of equations
so it seems like we can't find another
solution
but this is a puzzle and you have to
think creatively
how can we find another pair that equals
410
well think about the way you can read
410
they're actually two different ways
you can read it as 4 and a 10
or you can read it as 41 and 0.
so what happens if we read it as 41 and
0.
well we get the different set of
equations we get x minus y is equal to
41 and x plus y is equal to 0.
this ends up with the solution that x is
equal to 41 over 2 and y is equal to
negative 41 over 2
and this yields another solution
so 41 over 2 and negative 41 over 2 will
also combine to be 410
did you figure out this puzzle and the
challenge problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either mind your
decisions or at preshtalwalkar